ah Tick Tock you will never find a more
wretched Hive of scum and villainy the
algorithms there are just so good at
pushing stuff that's wrong today I'm
going to debunk a whole bunch of bad
tick tocks it's mostly going to be
skincare and I've responded to some of
these before on Tick Tock Instagram and
YouTube shorts but a shorter videos I
can only fit in a fraction of what I
want to talk about before it's too long
or complex and the algorithm just
ignores it so in this video I'm going
into more detail let's start with this
video bashing CeraVe you use this this
contains purple paraben purple paraben
is an estrogen-like compound that is
under this class of what we call
parabens women that are trying to get
pregnant or breastfeeding are told to
avoid paraben this is because they're
being researched to disrupt hormone
function in a negative way parabens are
in a lot of cosmetic products and I
would not want to rub these under my
skin my body's largest organ especially
as a man when you introduce an
estrogen-like compound that can disrupt
your testosterone levels so I don't use
this I think this is trash watching this
tiktok kind of made me feel like I was
back in the early 2010s parabens were
one of the first ingredient classes that
got demonized by the natural beauty
movement and then the clean Beauty
movement all of this was sparked by a
study in 2004 which found that parabens
were in breast cancer tissue the
researcher is called philippadabra she
has done a lot of research that's gotten
blown out of proportion so there were a
lot of issues with this study first off
they only looked at breast cancer tissue
they didn't compare it with healthy
tissues so parabens are probably in
those two and even if you only found the
parabens in the breast cancer tissue it
doesn't mean that parabens are causing
cancer it could be that cancer tissue
happens to collect parabens more it
could be some other thing that's
introducing parabens as well as some
cancer-causing ingredient it could be
something completely unrelated because
correlation isn't causation on top of
that in this study the blank samples
that didn't actually have any tissue at
all also had parabens so really all this
study showed is that parabens are used a
lot including in the detergents used to
clean lab equipment but this study got
blown up it was reported in newspapers
in forwarded emails on Facebook and so
this idea that parabens are bad and
they're related to breast cancer is just
in everyone's minds and it just keeps
spreading all of this paraben phobia
stuff was around even before I started
my blog back in 2011 so hi if you're new
here I'm Michelle of loudmouth and
Beauty science chemistry PhD cosmetic
chemist and person who has been annoyed
at misinformation on the internet for
way too long these days there are barely
any products on the market that have
parabens and he just happened to pick up
one of the ones that does there's also a
bunch of specific things he's saying
that a word of very carefully kind of
weasel words and I'm not sure he's even
aware he's doing this so he says women
that are trying to get pregnant or
breastfeeding are told to avoid parabens
who is telling them are they misinformed
is it just you telling them sometimes
apparently IVF clicks and
endocrinologists who are doctors who
specialize in hormones they will say
things like this but they don't
necessarily know much about things like
parabens and skin care and their impact
they're often going off things they've
come across on internet sources just
like well this guy one of my friends is
actually an endocrinologist and I
checked with her a couple of weeks ago
she has never been taught anything about
endocrine disruptors in skin care
parabens have been used for over 100
years they're a super popular
preservative that's in everything that
study was in 2004 there's been studies
since and it still hasn't made it onto
the medical syllabus and this is
actually a good sign that parabens
probably don't have that big of an
impact he also says this is because
they're being researched to disrupt
hormone function in a negative way and
yeah this is clever who is researching
this is it a scientist is it just you
googling what were the findings of This
research this phrase is a bit like
someone is being sued like it is not
that hard to sue someone being sued
doesn't really mean much except someone
either doesn't like you or thinks you
have Deep Pockets he says that
estrogen-like but in what way the
estrogenic activity of parabens are
generally thousands of tries less strong
the natural estrogen to begin with so
with purple paraben in the EU there's a
body called the scientific committee on
consumer safety and they look at the
safety of different cosmetic ingredients
going into cosmetics in the EU they
actually reviewed all of the evidence on
propyl paraben in 2021 because they were
going through a list of potential
endocrine disruptors and looking at all
of the data with fresh eyes They
concluded that propyl paraben is safe
when used in skin care products at the
previously recommended concentrations I
have another video that breaks down how
these evaluations work and as part of
this evaluation they looked up what
happened if you used the maximum
concentration in 17 different products
and they found that you still get 12 and
a half thousand times less than an
amount that they would still consider
safe whenever I talk about this
ingredient safety stuff I always get a
lot of comments asking don't the amounts
add up if you use more than one product
I think people tend to forget that
toxicologists the ones who do these
assessments are also normal people with
normal lives outside side of their work
they go home and use products too they
have partners and kids who use multiple
products like this is not a revelation
this is something that is taken into
account in the assessments now in
general big Brands like Sarah V they
make pretty much the safest products you
can buy I think a lot of people forget
to do like a reality check when they
accuse giant brands of trying to kill
them these big Beauty companies hire
tons of scientists if it was this easy
for someone who has zero Science
Background to just pick up a product and
look at the ingredient list and just
tell that it's unsafe they wouldn't have
released this product it would just not
happen this sort of stuff goes for
approval by lots of different people
including lots of scientists liability
is a thing on top of that dermatologist
recommends therapy all the time there's
just no chance that so many of them are
going around recommending something
obviously harmful another thing that
bothers me is that he goes on about how
the skin is the body's largest organ
except his holding a face cleanser which
is like your face is about four percent
of your body surface area I guess it
also depends how big your face is but
also Skin's main function is to act as a
barrier it would be really bad if it
just absorbs everything really
efficiently just because it's big it
would probably be safer to rub something
all over your skin your entire giant
body organ compared to rubbing it on
like I don't know your pancreas or
something and it'll probably also be a
lot safer to actually reach it in my
original response to this I said that I
really hate this genre of dudes who
don't understand science lettering
people on science while holding products
in supermarkets a handful of people got
really annoyed at me because reverse
sexism or whatever but if you've been on
Tick Tock for long enough you'll know
that this is a thing whether it's a
thing because more dudes film
Supermarket videos because I don't know
they don't actually own skincare so they
can't film at home or maybe the
algorithm is just picking up more dudes
lettering in supermarkets because people
are more willing to trust it at face
value when and it's a man these videos
just blow up and show up in my fade all
the time women obviously make BS tick
tocks that blow up too but they're not
the same genre it usually seems to be
like a woman in her bathroom or her
bedroom and she's holding a product or
she is throwing up products and she's
getting really upset sometimes there's
like tears in her eyes sometimes her
voice is really shaky and she's going on
about how there's all these chemicals
that she's never heard of in her
products and what are they doing to us
why are they trying to kill us social
media algorithms respond to signals from
people and people have biases there's
plenty of research that people tend to
believe technical information when it
comes from a man over when it comes from
a woman and that people accept emotional
things like crying more from a woman
than from a man we live in a society
even if you think you're 100 objective
and rational and not sexist there are
tons of people out there who are so deal
with it have you seen the ingredients oh
goddess Bobby all right so Bobby is a
home cook who makes videos about what
you mostly issued and shouldn't eat and
he recently started on personal care
products there's this trend of people
who used to make food content starting
to talk about how toxic personal care
products are and I think this is because
apps that usually look at food like the
ewg apps and Yuka they also have a
personal care section it's just really
easy to make scary content that goes
viral using these apps because you just
scan the product and you just read out
what comes up on your phone Bobby is
like a menace scientists and doctors are
constantly debunking his food content so
let's see what he has to say personal
care products they're scary are they
Bobby are they or do you just not know
these words anytime you see the word
paraben put it back especially prop or
paraben these are preservatives that
prevent mold from growing in here but
they're hormone disruptors endocrine
disruptors they mimic estrogen in your
body and for the ladies out there they
find more of that in your body because
it's in your lotions potions and makeup
all right so it's parabens again and the
sauce he's using here is the ewg's Skin
Deep database the ewg is not a
scientific source and honestly any app
that judges the safety of products just
based on the ingredients list which has
no information on concentration is
pseudoscience the amount is really
important in safety because the more
molecules are something that you're
exposed to the more chances it has to
interact with whatever part of the body
it has to interact with to cause harm
that's why you might have heard the
phrase the dose makes the poison a lot
from toxicologists the ewg specifically
has this really long history of
capitalizing on fear so for example they
used to promote the idea that vaccines
cause autism that whole thing was based
off a study that was mostly just what
did parents remember the stuff online
that explains why the ewg is bad is
mostly about how they approach food
safety but they use the same sort of
principles for evaluating Cosmetics so
there was this survey done by the
Society of Toxicology and they asked 937
members what they thought about
particular ideas 92 percent of their
respondents disagreed that any level of
exposure is unacceptable for chemicals
that have been identified as carcinogens
mutagens or reproductive toxicants
that is pretty much the methodology that
the ewg uses if it's in there it's bad
they also had 81 rejecting the notion
that the detection of any level of a
chemical in your body indicates a
significant health risk and yet this is
exactly what the ewg does in their
summaries there's also this article that
looked at the ewg's dirty dozen list
which looks at what foods tend to have
the most pesticide residues and there's
some really good quotes here but I think
the best one is probably the methodology
used to create the Jersey dozen list
does not appear to follow any
established scientific procedures and
that is pretty much the same for the
Skin Deep database pick up almost any
product here fragrance shaving cream
with fragrance and body wash with
perfume or fragrance that's the key word
if you see that put it back because
that's the Cosmetics version of natural
flavors but there can be up to 3 000
synthetic fragrances or perfumes in
there they're proprietary they ain't got
to tell you anything and they're linked
to reproductive issues and they find
these fragrances in breast milk it's
scary stuff you don't want it so yeah
finding stuff in your body is not a sign
that is scary there is a lot of stuff
online about how they don't tell you
the fragrances and therefore it's scary
so there's a pretty obvious reason they
don't tell you because fragrances are
Trade Secrets just like flavors just
like the Coca-Cola recipe there's all
this consumer research showing that the
first thing people do when they try a
product is they smell it smell is
associated with a lot of memories and
strong emotional responses and that's
why it isn't everything and it's so
secretive it's a large part of what
makes people buy products for fragrance
there's an organization called ephra
which is the international fragrance
Association it's full of fragrance
producers and they have rules that their
members have to follow I'll leave the
website below it tells you a lot about
them like they produce 80 of the global
volume of fragrance their rules are
based on safety assessments by the
Research Institute of fragrance
materials or rafm these are scientists
who look at fragrance safety and they
publish their safety Assessments in a
peer-reviewed journal there's also a
separate independent panel that reviews
what they do including how they design
their experiments these ifra standards
are really widely recognized and the
industry and by governments and
Regulators as well for example if you're
registering a cosmetic product in the EU
you can use an air for a compliance
certificate as part of your safety
dossier there are even regulations in
some countries that specifically refer
to the Air Force standards so basically
if you're buying a product that's from a
reputable brand it should comply with
the ifras standards and you can probably
ask them all right so let's say Bobby
isn't happy with that he wants to see
the full ingredient list what is he
going to do with it I mean I wouldn't
know what to do with it again there are
no concentrations on this thing if there
are concentrations then I would probably
take it to a toxicologist who knows
stuff about Cosmetics they would
probably just tell me to check those
concentrations against whatever
recommends because they're the people
who know the most about this and do all
the research so you would just end up at
the same place he also goes on about
hell it could have synthetics and this
happens a lot when it comes to cosmetic
fear-mongering we humans have this bias
towards assuming that natural things are
just safer and better it's called appeal
to nature but if you think about it for
a bit it's obviously just not true
nature is constantly trying to kill us I
am from Australia I know this very well
the most toxic substances known are
actually natural even the most toxic one
it can be safely used it is Botox and
this whole natural bias thing is
especially silly for fragrance because
it is really well established that
natural fragrances are full of allergens
which is one of the things he lists here
there are a bunch of allergens you have
to list out in your ingredients list in
certain regions like the EU and
Australia and most of these are things
you find in essential oil things like
linole and geranial maybe he doesn't
know this because he's in the U.S and
yes I do think this is something that
the U.S should start doing and with this
ewg entry they're generalizing 3 000
different chemicals here all of these
effects that they've got they probably
come from a small handful of these three
thousand they might not even be in your
fragrance if they are and you're buying
from a responsible brand then they're
going to be at an amount that the
evidence indicates is safe plus a lot of
essential oils have these effects as
well same as for fragrance these effects
just don't happen at the small amounts
used if the maker is being responsible
one thing I do sometimes worry about is
that some natural brands do use
essential oils and there are limits on
essential oils set by if fur as well
these Brands who are just dumping
essential oils and assuming that they
are safe they could be putting in way
too much so realistically that is going
to be a much bigger problem than
fragrances put in Things by big Brands
and yes you can avoid all fragrance
things if you want just in case but it
does mean that you're probably
unnecessarily restricting yourself so we
went on about finding stuff in breast
milk again having something in there
doesn't mean that much scientists have
gone really good at measuring tiny
amounts of stuff how do you think they
get this blue color in the body wash
while it's with blue one and red 33
artificial coloring but those are almost
always derived from tar or petroleum
loaded with toxins and many of these
colorants are banned in other countries
but not here this is really silly more
than usual just because something comes
from something scary doesn't mean it's
loaded with toxins when they're making
it they get rid of these toxins I mean
he's just been growing all these plastic
bottles which are also made from
petroleum plus the US is actually really
strict with colorants they're stricter
than pretty much anywhere else so the
FDA in the US actually certifies each
batch of colorants and this is from
their website the FDA determines the
need for bash certification based on
whether the color additives needs this
level of control to protect Public
Health some color additives in their
uncertified forms might contain
impurities at levels that pose a health
concern and colors subject to
certification are typically synthetic
made from raw materials obtained from
petroleum so literally the FDA is really
strict about these supposed toxins that
he's worried about so someone from the
FDA will actually analyze the sample
they'll look at lots of things including
Purity and they're specifically saying
they look full unreactive intermediates
colored impurities residual salts any
other unspecified impurities including
heavy metals if the sample doesn't meet
these requirements they reject the batch
and the FDA certifies color additives
before they're used in products so it's
illegal to use colors that aren't
certified and yeah this is a really high
level of control higher than these other
countries he's talking about ph balanced
for a woman that's strong enough for a
man but also with talc you don't want
help because talc and asbestos go hand
in hand which is why baby powder isn't
made with talc anymore because you can't
get rid of the asbestos you got to put
it back even though it's pH balance for
me and you
ah Bobby it's so dramatic I've talked
about talking asbestos before I'll link
the video down below but basically from
the evidence so far it is not that big
of a problem as is made out to be you
can actually see here the ewg only rates
it as a five which I'm actually kind of
surprised by it could be that there are
a lot of organic Brands who use it there
have been instances in the past where
the ewg will just like jiggle their
ratings allegedly for their Partners
their Partners pay a fee to be listed
nicely in their database allegedly one
thing I will say for Bobby is that his
shirts are great the Cosmetics industry
is not regulated nearly as much as the
food industry which is really scary
because this stuff goes on your body so
the question is what's the best
sunscreen as the summer comes upon us
first off stuff that goes on your body
is generally less scary than stuff that
goes in your body because yeah your skin
does act as a barrier sunscreen is a
drug not a Cosmetic in the US which is
where he is so he's talking about
entirely the wrong category here well
there's two kinds of sunscreen there's a
mineral based the good ones and chemical
based the bad ones
minerals are often made of zinc oxide
and that's good because it never
penetrates your skin the chemical based
ones are made with chemicals that
penetrate your skin and can be found in
your body in your breast tissue in baby
milk breast milk up to three or four
weeks later so minerals can penetrate
your skin especially
why a lot of places have a different
safety assessment so specifically for
nanoparticles I feel like I could just
post myself saying this to tick tock
like every week but the amount with
normal use doesn't seem to be a big
health risk because that is like the
basis for all of these safety
assessments and that is pretty much the
same situation for chemical sunscreens
although obviously for different
substances it will be different
percentages you have a huge range within
chemical sunscreens as well because a
lot of the new ingredients were
specifically designed to not get through
skin easily there were these studies on
sunscreens done by the FDA a while ago
which was all publicized as sunscreens
get all the way into your blood this is
not new information but the nice thing
about the FDA studies is that they said
how much Ashley gets in there if you do
a bunch of rough calculations you'll see
that only a fraction of a percent of
most of these chemical sunscreens get
absorbed also if you're wondering the
safety assessments do take into account
developing fetuses usually that is the
endpoint that they're based on I talk
about that in my EU sunscreen video so
this whole good ingredient bad
ingredient thing really makes me cringe
because it is just such a big red flag
good and bad depends entirely on dose
and specifically in sunscreen zinc oxide
does have tons of downsides which I've
talked about before the main one is that
it is not very good as a sunscreen you
need lots of it to absorb a relatively
small amount of UV people also under
apply it because it's got a white cast
and it usually has a thick sticky
texture it's also not that great for the
environment despite what everyone seems
to be assuming I'll probably make a
video on that later too when you pick up
a chemical based one you're always going
to see the same active ingredients Arbor
benzone hamasa League aptizolate these
are the kind of chemicals you want to
avoid and if you're ever thinking about
using any kind of spray spray bottle
like this avoid it because when it goes
into the air it can be inhaled into your
lungs and coat the inside of your body
if you want to see a video about the
best mineral based sunscreens let me
know and I'll make a part two of the
video this is so weird like he says coat
the inside of your body like you don't
have stuff inside your body with spray
sunscreens I personally don't really
like them because there are a lot of
downsides the point that he made about
how you could inhale it is actually a
good point the health risk from inhaling
sunscreen is generally quite low it's
taken into account in the safety
Assassins but the risk is higher for
mineral sunscreens but I think it's
still not a very nice experience to
breathe it all in and you end up with
lower protection because your insides do
not need protection from the Sun alright
that is enough Bobby for me today he
mostly makes food content so if you want
to see people debunking that I highly
recommend food science babe she is a
legend I'm pretty sure her eye rolling
muscles must be super buff because
that has made me tired our next
estrogenic is sunscreens I don't know of
any sunscreen with a chemical UV filter
in it that doesn't have some affinity
for hormonal receptors in the human body
some of the common ones are benzophenone
three or bp3 benzylidine camphor 3 BC
4-methylbenzylidine camphor or four MBC
but there are dozens of them watch out
for the root bends or Fen in the
chemical name better yet just don't use
a chemical based sunscreen all right
this one is a bit more complicated
because he does talk about a lot of
technical stuff he's a pharmacist and he
mostly runs a business advising people
on how to fix their hormones my PhD is a
Medicinal Chemistry I also did
pharmacology in undergrad so receptors
are like one of my things you know my
buddy old Pals so he says sunscreens all
have affinity for hormone receptors and
yeah that is probably true and not that
surprising because lots of substances
will bind to receptors in our bodies but
the issue is that that alone just
doesn't tell you very much so first off
binding which just means the sunscreen
molecule comes along and sticks to a
hormone receptor inside your body that
doesn't just mean a negative effect
because how well something buys how
sticky it is that doesn't necessarily
have a good relationship with what it
actually does there obviously it has to
stick to do something but what it does
there is a huge range things that bind
to the same receptor can have completely
opposite effects or even no Effect one
more common example is with opioid
receptors which is where feel is like
Fentanyl and heroin will act both of
those will have affinity for the
receptor so in other words they will
stick to it but they also have efficacy
which means they will actually trigger
some sort of effect there you might have
heard of Narcan or naloxone which is
used to treat opioid overdoses and the
way that that works is also by binding
to the same receptors but actually they
have more Affinity they stick more
strongly but it doesn't actually trigger
anything there so it's got really really
low or no efficacy so it essentially
kicks out the heroin or fentanyl or
whatever the person's overdosing on it's
a bit like a key and a lock so both
heroin and Fentanyl can open this
particular lock but naloxone is sort of
like a key that fits in the lock but it
doesn't open the door and it actually
gets stuck there and so it blocks keys
that will actually do something and on
top of that binding Affinity is about
what happens when your sunscreen and the
receptor actually meet but the substance
actually has to get to the receptor in a
high enough concentration first and
where that receptor is in your body can
mean that binding there will trigger
different effects so this all sounds
really scary because it's unfamiliar and
Technical but it doesn't really mean
much sunscreens still need to be
assessed for safety on a case-by-case
basis and that is actually what happens
for sunscreens to get approved and that
goes for both chemical sunscreens and
physical sunscreens chemical sunscreens
are lipophilic meaning they're attracted
to fat and we all have a fatty layer in
our skin so a lot of it absorbs right in
doesn't just stay on the surface
remember the Skin's an effective dosing
route for hormones and drugs applied as
creams so yes it acts as a barrier and
protection from exposures to lots of
different things but to substances with
the right properties your skin is like a
wide open unguarded back door and what
goes in through the skin dumps right
into the bloodstream without being
metabolized At All by the liver like
food and other things we eat which go to
the liver first and then into the
circulation it's like getting these
chemicals by injection
yikes so here is another bunch of
arguments that aren't quite right but
they do have some grain of Truth and
they sound complicated and scary enough
that people aren't going to question him
so let's break down all of this stuff
first off sunscreens are lipophilic that
means they're oil loving the thing is
though things that are true lipophilic
they don't actually get through skin
easily he makes a sound like the fatty
layer under the dermis which is the
hypodermis it's like
there somewhere it makes it sound like
that is like a magnet that just sucks
lipophilic things like chemical
sunscreens through the skin but the way
that lipophilic oil loving things stick
to Fat oil is through forces called
dispersion forces and these are really
short range they don't act like a magnet
they can't suck things through the skin
essentially the chemical sunscreen has
to bump into the fat or oil before it
sticks like I think we all know that if
you rub coconut oil or just like a
greasy sunscreen on your skin it doesn't
all get sucked through you can't feed
Yourself by rubbing coconut oil on he is
correct though that some substances can
get through skin really easily if they
have the right properties but that is
not many things and that is not chemical
sunscreens there are a lot of
medications that are meant to get into
the bloodstream and spread that way but
so few of them are delivered as creams
if injections and creams did the same
thing we just would never inject things
injections are so much more annoying and
painful if we could get them through
easily without injections then yeah that
would be amazing so things that do go
through skin easily they actually have
to have the right balance of lipophilic
and hydrophilic things that are very
lipophilic like he says they don't get
through easily skin has both water and
oil so you can see on my handy skin
model we have the blood here and to get
to the blood stuff has to go through a
bunch of different layers and these
layers are complex there are oily layers
the top layer for example is oily that's
the stratum corneum it has that brick
and mortar structure and the mortar
between the bricks is very oily and then
you also have more watery areas as well
as you go down so if a particular
chemical is too lipophilic it likes oil
too much or is too hydrophilic it likes
water too much it gets stuck on its way
to the bloodstream chemical sunscreens
are quite lipophilic so most of them
actually get stuck in this top layer of
the stratum corneum that's actually how
chemical sunscreens sink in a bit and
they last for longer than physical
sunscreens so to get into the blood it's
not just about being lipophilic it's got
to be the right balance of not too
lipophilic not too hydrophilic and we do
have data on how much chemical sunscreen
absorb into blood and for most of these
it is a fraction of a percent like I
said before working out how much of a
chemical is likely to absorb into blood
is part of that toxicological assessment
that's done for sunscreens he also
didn't seem to realize that the secs has
gone through the data on benzophenone3
which is oxybenzone as well as for MBC I
mentioned before that they were only
looking at potential endocrine
disruptors and only a few sunscreens
actually made it to the list so only a
handful of chemical sunscreens have
enough evidence that it's worth
reassessing for the ones they have
assessed they found that there isn't
enough evidence to say any of them are
endocrine disruptors except perhaps for
NBC check out my video for more on that
so the reason that they've ended up at a
different conclusion from him is that he
is just looking at studies and taking
them at face value he's assuming what
happens in the study is exactly the same
as what happens when we apply sunscreen
on our skin but studies in the
literature generally aren't done under
realistic conditions so a lot of the
time it's animal and cell line studies
which they're obviously not the same as
humans even with human studies they
usually use really artificial conditions
like using way too much sunscreen in the
proper assessments like the ones done by
the secs they translate the study so
that they're actually relevant to how
normal people use sunscreens and that's
how they come up with the guidelines
that formulators follow when they're
making the sunscreens it is all based on
the same evidence it's just that
toxicologists are interpreting the
studies in a nuanced and scientific way
whereas other people are just not
actually doing interpretation they say
well I don't often use sunscreen so this
really isn't an issue for me but
remember it's in cosmetics too like
makeup skin creams even some soaps so
daily applications a likelihood for a
lot of people now chemical UV filters
are required to be listed as an
ingredient in cosmetic products but
protecting human skins is not their only
use they also protect other materials
from the harmful effects of UV light
like Plastics carpet furniture and all
of this is taken into account in
toxicological assessments it really
drives me off the wall when people say
but it adds up like it's some sort of
huge Revelation it is not a huge
Revelation it is really obvious everyone
from the age of I don't know 20 maximum
onwards we know that we use more than
one product toxicologists do this every
day as part of their jobs they would
have thought of this I've been thinking
about this for a pretty long time and
I'm probably going to do a video on it
it is actually quite depressing and
disturbing how much misinformation is
spreading and how social media
algorithms are really boosting it it is
just so much faster to scan ingredients
where some BSF and make a tick tock
about how scared you should be than to
actually work out the reality of what's
going on and figure out how to explain
it in a way that people can understand
there are also just so many more people
who can make this easy misinformation
than people who have the knowledge to
debunk all of their claims so there's
just more BS content to begin with and
then there's a social media algorithm
part if you know anything about social
media marketing you'll know that these
algorithms generally reward one
capturing people's attention in a really
short time span and two engagement it is
so much faster to explain some
simplified BS concept than complex messy
science and this sort of fear-mongering
is such an engagement magnet because
we're humans we care about other people
if we find out that something common is
dangerous we're going to share it with
people we care about we are mostly good
people so these sorts of videos just get
pushed by algorithms as everyone shares
it and tags it and it is just this
massive compounding effect so knowing
this I think there are some things that
we can do to fight it first off be
careful before sharing videos if it's
something scary that is a massive red
flag if it talks about babies or
pregnancy or cancer if it's someone
unqualified it's also a red flag and yes
sometimes unqualified people can share
scary things that are true but these are
just signs that you should switch on
your critical thinking I think it's also
good to do a reality check large
companies have hundreds thousands of
scientists if some unqualified person
can quickly work out that they're all
making toxic products there's like zero
chance that all of these scientists have
missed it or that they're all covering
it up big conspiracies involving
hundreds of people just do not work
because people do not keep their mouths
shut if you want to work out what's
actually true my advice is to look for
the consensus of relevant experts you
want to check with experts from multiple
relevant Fields see what they mostly
seem to be saying and that is likely
going to be true or at least it won't
hurt you sometimes it can be hard to
work out who the relevant experts are
and which expert would know more so for
example if you remember the Benzene and
sunscreen thing when that first came out
journalists seem to assume that
dermatologists know tons about Benzene
for some reason but clearly most
dermatologists haven't even seen Benzene
in their life the most relevant experts
are toxicologists and they were saying
something completely different from
dermatologists and even within
toxicology it is a really diverse field
so a toxicologist who does academic
research on frogs in the US might not
know anything about cosmetics in the EU
and there are malicious experts out
there who can be paid off and also just
incompetent people in every field and
that's why the consensus part is
important if a bunch of relevant experts
overwhelmingly say the same thing it is
probably what's going to be true based
on the current evidence I hope that's
useful I'm sorry to be such a Debbie
Downer but this stuff is like a flood
tag me on Tick Tock and Instagram if you
see any posts that need debunking and of
course follow me on there if you enjoyed
this video click the like and the
subscribe to teach the algorithm that
this is what you like seeing leave any
myths you want me to debunk in the
comments I'll see you next time and
until then don't film Supermarket
lectures